[Music]
Rachel thanks so much for being here and
on Halloween happy Halloween you are
from Canada where in Canada are you from
I'm from outside of Toronto okay all
right really don't being outside yeah
they just like they're like we're from
outside something too
[Laughter]
here's my question I have no idea if
Halloween's a big deal in Canada is it a
big deal I think so yeah it feels like
it I celebrated it every year for a long
time but how is it how is it different
say than here in the United States well
it's so much usually so much colder it's
like minus five degrees so so it changes
the costume a bit you know like you have
to put your snowsuit on so every
character every costume is I'm Yoda in a
parka yeah I was a fairy princess with a
turtleneck and I just I was so upset I
was so bitter about that it limits your
choices too I would think yeah so you
know you see it's in here in the states
it's a time for a lot of ladies like to
go with these sexy costumes and you
can't do that if it's minus five and
you're you know wrapped in insulation
yeah like five layers of pantyhose yeah
I'm the [ __ ] Michelin Man
I don't think it's the same but
everything else is the same you give it
the candy Orcas some countries have the
tradition but it's they've they like
only give out fruit you know like they
give out like a chestnut you're like
come on that's not Halloween this should
be candy that's really bad for ya we
would always go back later on and smash
that house with well we were bad kids
now I would think talk about a place
that's really nice to hang out you are
now shooting a movie in Hawaii is that
right yes yeah yeah it's gonna be
fantastic
it's pretty great yeah I mean the ocean
is right there every day and I go out
and and swim and you know just it's it's
beautiful I mean I I was swimming every
morning I was getting because I was so
jet-lagged coming from Toronto there's
six hours behind in Hawaii so I was
getting up at like 4:00 in the morning
going okay well I guess I'll go for a
swim and so instead of waiting till like
6:00 you know so the Sun was coming up
with a beautiful time to go for a dip
yeah and I was on really busy beach in
Waikiki there's people everywhere and no
one's in the water and I was like this
is so strange
I mean it's lovely to have the ocean to
myself but and then Bradley Cooper and I
were talking to the other day because
he's shooting the I'm not just saying
you know you're not name-dropping cuz I
just saw Bradley Cooper this morning you
know he stayed over at my place whatever
but anyway what did he say yeah and he
said I've been going for these sunset
swims and I've noticed there's no one in
the water so anyway I heard about shark
attacks in Hawaii and it suddenly dawned
on me
is it feeding time for sharks
when is the feeding time sunrise and Sun
oh that's why I know what yeah so you're
in there you're basically in when the
dinner bell is ringing for all sharks
right right right right and and are you
how are you do just wearing I mean are
you wearing
not what you're not supposed to wear
like bright colors you're not supposed
to wear jewelry cuz the the sparkle
makes you look like a fish I'm blinged
out you're blinged out and your your
method of swimming is to thrash wildly
we're an Olympic Thrasher and you're
wearing your good luck porkchop around
but I mean I do in defense of sharks you
know I I did also look up how many shark
attacks have been and there have been
only nine people have died from
unprovoked shark attacks since 1828 in
Hawaii right that's hardly any also yeah
if someone if someone dies have a
provoked shark attack then they have it
coming you know when someone says those
were unprovoked with their say what
about that one that guy was in there
like what you got shot shot that guy has
it coming
yeah